where is where is where well it's not
there
Horace boy this works ok Garba thank you
oh that feels good
thank you go man my best friend you've
been there since the beginning since
series ups gobble who's here
Berta Bo level 2 else we have to wear
the shirt in every shot if you see us
not wearing the shirt we get a strike
the one that with the most strikes after
21 days after 21 days has to go to
achieve tattoo Paulo and get an American
flag tattoo so that's what's happening
with the shirt in case you don't know I
have to go to the gym today which I have
a bunch of problem this way because
eight you can see I'm good dammit number
one it's veneer as Jim is like 30
minutes away
number 2 I have to wear this shirt to
the gym and I can't take it off number 3
I'm jet lag and I have a headache
and I I'm really excited about this vlog
today let me tell you more about what's
gonna happen today today starts the
first day I'm scared papa
and my whole time is at 10 p.m. last
night I went to sleep at that time and I
was very very tired and I was supposed
to be done at 4 a.m. I'm doing today
today's video just went up let's check
some comments your content is [ __ ] again
all right so now I'm going to rent a car
for LA don't know why I specified that
[Music]
I think we're going for this one but I'm
pretty sure my state would want that one
because it's the ugliest one it's really
ugly
all right a guy recognized for the first
time
yeah how do you say that hello from
Ceylon okay well that's it okay so this
is my car I picked it because Marty I
loves squared ugly cars
it's my Lambo got pretty nice got pretty
sweet rims neck end that's a really good
really good brain I'm on the wrong side
[ __ ] how do I Drive oh my god
it's like driving in LA is bad enough
driving with a new car on the wrong side
of the road with no GPS I don't even
know how the [ __ ] to get back I didn't
think this I should have just gotten
like a nice Tesla or some [ __ ] [ __ ]
what is oh my god it's automatic where's
the gas bag oh I'm legit scared right
now
alright I don't know what the [ __ ] today
Oh God
alright I'm gonna stop talking now Oh
God
[Music]
I'm hung thank you for cooking what did
you make man
oh hey Italian meatballs Swedish Italian
me pop thank you Maggie
am I supposed to eat with my hands get
me my cutlery
can you believe okay let's give this a
go oh my god are you ready
thank you really good okay I know what
it is we like food the day after is
better because I made with love thank
you
thought so many times they were back
home
something was in here I swear I saw
something in here I don't know it's
something made to move here oh oh oh ah
there's something it's something scary
where is it oh my god it was cover cover
what were you doing there oh my god
you scared he's scared me that was crazy
okay I'm gonna show mercy out of the car
I hope you like a Marzia are you excited
Martin
very excited can't really film here it's
the one you wanted this squared well I
knew you'd like a square one
wait suck up
cowbells
what are you he's always up to something
oh my god where are you going wait grab
us come come here let's just get you out
stupid okay we're going to get some
Halloween costumes I started working at
5:00 today so we won't be much of a
Halloween thanks for that
YouTube gobbles look after the house
while I'm gone so where are we going ma
yeah
yeah costumes for Halloween the Chokey i
might pick up something for me actually
while I'm here we need to get Michaels
let's buy Michael a birthday present
yeah I feel like we should get in
something really weird or really bad
it's very moving for the vlog
like it
No broke we can buy a printer and then
we can print the picture of us yeah
here we saw how these new print up hold
on buddy you just came out of the closet
Hey
edit that out serious now edit that out
and it's a tie
like pumpkin say pumpkin ball got to
change into my outfit
I'm wearing the shirt don't you worry
about it Michael what are you doing
[Music]
so I'm a little bummed out because we
don't get to really celebrate Halloween
because I have to work the first scare
shoot starts at 5:00 but we're gonna
hang out a little bit before we're gonna
carve some pumpkins or whatever so we
get to do a little bit what can you do I
was really excited to celebrate
Halloween in America because they do it
so well oh well look who's coming
look who's here is he wearing this shirt
yeah he's wearing this shirt hey hey
brand-new wait a second what do you mean
I'm wearing it you're not wearing I'm
wearing it this is the home yeah it
doesn't matter it's on my body should be
at least underneath oh yeah
viewers am I wearing it right now as a
scar am i wearing this I don't think so
yeah I think so let's turn around it's a
trump wing oh my gosh sketch time to
make scooby doo great again
okay I'm not allowed to [ __ ] with
anyone's shirt but they just left their
shirts so you have to do this you have
to miss me
please mom I have no chance come on hey
my chance I'm gonna go you go I can't I
can't do it that was two rules that I
can't do it directly they are out there
this is the part of the game my it says
two innocent for this I'm leaving you're
forcing her to do is that even with any
pants on yeah okay let's not tell them
anything
oh I'm so happy thank you so much
don't tell them okay
oh my gosh oh my god that's adorable
look at Dan as me marches and breads get
crushed
dammit Brad every time hey guys I want
to be part of the picture
on the way back oh please you wanna be
in it too well ain't that beautiful look
at that
leave a comment which one is the best
Europeans are fascinated by the what did
you call them their waste spawn so we
don't have it in Europe okay guys we
don't know what it's like alright I got
10 minutes until I'm getting picked up
by stare peopIe it begins now
it's like why you spy hell yeah Cologne
and look at us who did this what is it
[Music]
perfectly always your friend that is the
end of our relationship that's right it
looks so good like I said my god yes
tired that's all that's happened to
everyone even the Mafia tender it's time
it begins now
wait we all got the [ __ ] shirts hell
yeah uh-huh yeah a little bit all right
the cars here we're gonna go this has
literally been the whole season one just
sitting in the back of a van
now we're now yeah my night in Hazzard
and my Colette skirt we do
[Music]
we've stopped after how long have you
been driving two hours yet she says
Christ I'm ready to go to sleep oh you
put it up I've locked to the window now
they're blocking out the windows great
all right here it goes
I think I know what game it is I think
it's out lies
Oh [ __ ] hell that's sexual harassment
what are you expecting to see when you
get out ah something really horrifying
like your mom's deer touches but - I
know I am touching but I judge a lot of
dudes but that aren't my boyfriend
[Music]
okay I'll go this way this seems and
anyone tested this is not this is 20
bucks to [ __ ] with Felix's shirt you
want to draw on it I put like a little
dick hanging down just from the flag
like just like a tiny plastic and on the
back for I heart Michael okay cuz you
hates Michael oh you want to wear a
little sharp want to keep wearing it
[Music]
food food apparel was it that was
horrible I want to go her sick I'm
really cold that was happening I want to
go I got my shower here it's a portable
little shower it's 2:00 a.m. we started
at 5:30 such a long day
it was awesome though I'm just ready to
go home Oh Louise eat oh oh
so [ __ ] good oh my god thanks for
watching part 2 a part about this was a
crazy day it really they stepped it up
from the high season this is like 10
times more
it's crazy I can't believe it I hope you
guys are enjoying the vlogs I'll see you
tomorrow but then on the brighter book
brofist
[Music]